milk shakers welcome to another
scintillating
ideological bubbly philosophical episode
of metaphysical milkshake i am rain
wilson
and i am reza aslan and rain you know we
record these episodes obviously a little
bit earlier than then you hear them but
uh
today is kind of a solemn day for our
nation
today is the day that we're told that
kova deaths have reached one
million
americans and of course we all know it's
much more than that really so it's
definitely an under count but you know
it's a
it's a threshold that's difficult to
wrap wrap our minds around yeah it
really is uh it's it's absolutely
devastating and i remember those early
weeks when people were online saying
this isn't real it doesn't exist it's
not a real disease
it's all a fabrication it's just the flu
it just pisses me off so much and here
we are
a million dead yeah a lot of them
were in poor health a lot of them were
held the elderly but that doesn't matter
uh a million people died before their
time and
um
it's really
it's really sad
and i wonder if you know
if there is one positive thing that
could come out of this experience which
is
kind of a grotesque thing to say if you
think about it
maybe it has the ability to change our
country's attitude towards death the way
that we
think about death and deal with death i
mean we you know we've talked about this
on on previous episodes the fact that
you know americans we don't like to talk
or think about death right we do
everything we can
to keep it as far away from us as
possible but
you know these last couple of years
it's been hard to avoid the topic and
the question
and a majority of americans
say from a study that uh
more than half actually are thinking
more about mortality because of
it 19 and its presence
the british historian arnold toynbee
once remarked that death was unamerican
because you're right america is all
about youth culture and beauty virility
ambition athletic prowess you know
material success
um
and it's really funny because the um
the victorians were obsessed with death
actually and they would talk about it
all the time they had seances they would
visit dead bodies and morgues
photos that they used to take
that's like the photos of the corpses
chronicling the dead hanging dead body
pictures up in their houses
and we're obsessed with sex america is
all about sex xxx
just go to any old website and you'll
see like
so and so stuns in her sizzling hot
bikini welcome to metaphysical milkshake
the show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
but it's interesting death is something
that has always
really fascinated me and intrigued me
kind of
and not in a macabre way but just a
curiosity it's it's it is the one thing
we all have in common you and me reza
and everyone listening to the show and
um
one of my great privileges in life was
to be able to make a show about death i
produced a show called my last days for
soul pancake which was my old digital
media company and platform and
uh the great filmmaker justin baldoni uh
did uh
directed and produced an excellent
series about lessons that we can learn
about life
from those at the end of their life
and it's always the same it's always the
same it's connection it's love it's
gratitude for what we have it's savor
every precious day it's love people
connect with them look them in the eyes
celebrate nature
uh
laugh together make music together break
bread together
um this is
this
you know this incessant lesson that we
learn from death and it's interesting
because
we took this show it was an incredibly
popular show i mean hundreds of millions
of views
on this show about death who would have
thunk
um
and we pitched it around town we're like
there's got to be a like a tv show
version of this right
we went into mtv sat in a room full of
executives back when mtv was a thing
and
we showed them our sizzle reel some
sections of the show
we ended it there in this conference
room
they were sobbing all of them were in
tears tears pouring down the face of
television executives which is no mean
feat let me tell you and they were like
as they were wiping their tears like
that was so beautiful oh my god this
show is so exquisitely done is amazing
we can't air it we can't show it i'm so
sorry that'll never happen we can't do a
show about death yeah how would we
possibly get advertisers to advertise
you know cheerios and toyotas and dr
scholes
while are you watching people
dying which of course is such a shame
because as you rightly note
there are so many
lessons to be learned about life from
confronting death
you know
um
so much to understand about you know
what life is about what it means to to
live
if we are just willing to
take a look at death
just stare it right in the eyes for
a little bit and and that's the topic uh
for the pod today milkshakers
what can we learn about life
from death we've brought in someone with
a great perspective about this uh adam
robarts has written this book 19 19
insights learned from a 19 year old with
cancer i'd really
uh have enjoyed reading this book it's
very thoughtful extremely touching very
sensitive
incredibly thought provoking but really
like heart provoking yeah adam robarts
was born in london raised in uganda in
kenya
he lived in the uk he had an
award-winning design firm in china all
of his children all four of them were
born and raised in beijing
and he
uh at one point in time was asked you
know if you couldn't be an architect
what occupation would you want to have
and he said
without uh pause a hospice nurse
and well um
in a tragic fashion uh he became a
hospice nurse uh for nine and a half
months uh with his
son
hayden 19 years old uh and accompanied
him on a battle
a losing battle with a rare brain cancer
and um
uh he shares these beautiful and
poignant lessons learned on the family's
journey through this process in his book
let's welcome to the show adam robarts
you're dialing in from bali i am yes the
other side of the world
wow we're honored we're so honored
it always sounds like i should be sounds
like i should be on holiday in bali so i
prefer to say i'm dialing in
from indonesia or something like that
it's a little bit more right
right indonesia sounds more formal
business-like
i found your book 19 insights learned
from a 19 year old with cancer i found
it really beautiful poignant moving
touching thought provoking
um so i'm very very sorry for the loss
of you and your family
um i got to uh
meet hayden very briefly when he was
sick
on a on a little zoom call to say hello
um but i didn't know him very well
um
and know your family a little bit uh
your sister sarah and um
other folks in your circle
but i guess you know
one of the things i was really struck by
and it brought up a lot for me
was over this last year i lost two of my
very best friends to cancer
um in the midst of this
incredible
pandemic where we've lost a million
people in the united states we just the
other day hit one million yeah lost to
covid um in the middle of that i had two
friends battling
cancer till the very end uh
suffering greatly incredible amounts of
pain and um
it was uh it was devastating it was
devastating and
this part of what this book does is it
chronicles your kind of year and a half
struggle with your dying son trying kind
of every kind of treatment that's out
there and
and at the same time
and this is where
it uh it differs a little bit with my
friends my friends were also
trying struggling to find any possible
positive outcome any possible cure um
experimental therapies etc
um anything they could to you know eat
healthy and and hold on to as much life
as possible but what you also chronicle
in the book is
the process with hayden of
uh who's 18 years old 19 years old as
this is happening
of getting in tune with our mortality
and kind of
getting right with god for lack of a
better phrase
and aligning oneself with the
inevitability
um
sorrow tragedy but also majesty of death
and
um
so you have all these different layers
and stories and textures and of course
it's chock-a-block with incredible
spiritual lessons and we'll get to some
of those later on but
ultimately
when he was passing did he know you were
going to write a book did you guys have
a conversation like i think i'm gonna
document some of that would this be okay
hayden or was this a book that came out
kind of after the fact and really
ultimately what inspired you to write
this
well
who
of all rain i also sorry for your
grief
and your losses and i think you lost
your father last year didn't you or was
it the year before i did hearing
something that yes yes that was not
cancer but yes uh there was a lot of
death all around in in my life and in
the country's life yeah the globe's life
yeah
so here is a book about
facing death and approaching that veil
to whatever lies beyond
um but it's not a book that is meant to
stop there the purpose of the book
is to help us to live more fully
to live more purposefully
and
actually
it's so interesting that you use the
word majesty
i think reign you said the majesty of
death
i i don't use that expression in the
book but i wish i had
i think it's very powerful
and so much
of what death is about is
is majestic it's awesome
um so where did this come about well
first of all
we were thrown into this unknown world
of accompanying a 19 year old
with his life ahead of him wonderful
prospects ahead of him about to study
architecture
suddenly out of the blue he's diagnosed
with brain cancer an aggressive
brain cancer and so we spent nine and a
half months in and out of hospitals and
looking for treatments of different
kinds in addition to the normal
sort of cut
burn
poison you know of surgery radiotherapy
um and uh chemotherapy
so yeah we did not expect to write a
book i never told hayden i would write a
book i had no intention of writing a
book
but during that course every
week every week or so
i would send out an email to friends and
family
and this email would basically
usually ask for prayers
but it would give a little bit of an
update on what we were doing and also
what we were feeling
and at the end of the journey after
hayden had passed away
i received three or four emails from
friends who said you should publish
those emails
all right so that's really the sort of
the the seed the germ of this book came
from that
very simple suggestion you know take the
emails and do something with them i
didn't intend to publish a book
but i thought if it's really just
putting the emails together i'm sure i
can do that
interestingly after hayden passed away
we found in a little black notebook he
kept beside his bed
some notes
that
gave us the impression he planned to
write a book he was kind of like notes
to self
and there was even a title
for the book
um the title for hayden's book seems
from his notes that he was exploring the
idea he says title
take the self
out of self-help
i mean i think that would destroy a
whole industry so we didn't use that
title but interestingly he also said
use quotes from all religions
and which
you did throughout the book certainly i
did yeah every chapter begins with a
kind of sprinkling of wisdom
um from the different religions from
buddhism
hinduism judaism christianity islam the
baha'i faith
and that's a tribute to hayden
adam what do you what do you think he
meant by take the self out of self-help
how do you interpret that
you know there's a lot of focus on
self and self-help and looking after
ourselves and taking care of ourselves
and
books and books on shelves and shelves
and bookshops and bookshops
but
hayden was remarkably
self
less
he always was looking out for others and
trying to
bring joy
to others rain you mentioned that you
had a chance to chat
with hayden just before he passed away
you know the context of that
was hayden asked two people
who were very close to him his mum
and his younger brother
what wish they would like to have
fulfilled
hayden's younger brother keon
is a fan of the office has watched it
over and over and over again
and
he
hayden knew this
and hayden thought you know what i'm
going to surprise keon
i'm going to put him in touch with rayne
wilson
surprised he figured it out i think
through my sister sarah he managed to
get a phone number for urane and one day
almost maybe two or three weeks before
he passed away
hayden sat up in his bed
and the phone call
was made
and he called keon over and said kian
i've got a surprise for you this is a
call for you
and it was rain wilson at the other end
so you know how sweet and selfless
there was hayden looking after others
and making their wishes come true
so
take the self out of her self help with
so much about hayden
always thinking of others
the geeked podcast is your weekly energy
boost of the worlds fandoms and stories
you love hosted by princess weeks author
youtuber and connoisseur of all things
sailor moon and buffy the vampire slayer
and tessa netting who's an actress
musical theater nerd and lover of all
fictional villains
each week these two will break down the
top stories in the land of geekdom and
then they'll take a deep dive into the
lore of netflix worlds bigger than our
own worlds like stranger things the
umbrella academy love that show the
witcher and many more you'll also get to
hear some of your favorite actors and
creatives talk about fun behind the
scenes tidbits and of course what they
are geeking out about this podcast is a
must listen for anyone who is scouring
twitter threads and fan wikis dying to
theorize and talk about that new show
they're all obsessed with
interviews include breakout stars from
stranger things and umbrella academy as
well as cultural critics and
professional geeks like you rain new
episodes of the geeked podcast come out
weekly follow the geeked podcast on
apple podcasts spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts and be sure to follow
at netflix geeked on twitter instagram
and tick tock
there's a famous study of dr martin
seligman who's the kind of founder of
the movement in the 90s
gave his
students forgive me milkshakers if i've
told this story before it's one of my
favorite ones but he told his psychology
students
to spend one weekend
going out and
um doing anything that they thought
would make them more happy
and they had previously taken a
happiness test to kind of set their
baseline
and so they went out that weekend they
drank they gambled they they they hooked
up they went shopping they went to the
beach you know all this stuff they came
back they took the happiness test again
they scored lower and then the following
weekend he's like i want you to go out
and be of service to someone else this
weekend it could be anything call your
grandmother hold the door open at the
grocery store visit a sick friend etc
like that and
and then they took the happiness test
again
that week after they got back and if
lo and behold their happiness scores
were higher so
this whole you know we're stuck in this
mode in the united states of like oh
i don't know about self-help necessarily
or self-care but i would say um
a kind of selfish pursuit of pleasure
um actually doesn't make us happier you
know i don't think anyone is saying like
don't do things that are pleasurable but
pursuing hookups gambling
drinking bouts
shopping binges what what have you
don't actually increase happiness but
serving others actually does work so
this is
you know this is verifiable there's
there's data around this
this pleasure seeking
worlds that we have created in the west
you know where we really focus
on
how to find pleasure to in order to find
happiness it's not working
you know so what is the alternative to a
pleasure
centered framework a pleasured centered
goal
you know in the eastern world
you know china was where hayden grew up
you know the focus is much more on
growth the purpose of life is to grow
and of course pleasure has its place
and it's a very wonderful part of growth
that we
enjoy it we enjoy the journey but if
growth is our focus
then when pain comes along
it's okay because pain has its place
in promoting growth in stimulating
growth in everything from nature
the way a seed breaks and becomes a tree
to living the life of a human being
whereas if pleasure is our focus when
pain comes along it's like disaster
right
you know that's not not not what we
planned
so i think shifting from a pleasure
focused orientation to a growth
focused orientation to our lives
allows us to deal with much more to
accept the pleasure but also to accept
when things don't go the way we expect
which was very much
this journey of suffering and the
journey that i think in the u.s with the
one million covet deaths that you
mentioned rain
you know this is not what we bargained
for but how can we accept it
if pleasure is the focus
and especially when we think about
where is this pleasure coming from
because if it's coming from the body
then we're really in trouble
you know i think in the western world we
are in danger of
idolizing the mortal body
you know and idolizing the mortal body
makes death ultimately the worst thing
that could happen
you know that's when the mortal body
collapses and the idol is shattered so
we'll do everything we can to protect
that idol keep it on its pedestal
so idolizing the mortal body is a
is a rut we've got ourselves into and we
need to shatter
the idol of the mortal body
yeah you know especially here in the
united states we've talked about this
before on previous pods
you know we don't like to think about
death death is a thing that we try to
keep
um as distant from our experience as
possible most people even in the midst
of this horrific
pandemic
don't want to be faced with their own
mortality you know we we try to keep it
at arm's length but and i wonder if
you know
hayden went through
almost a year uh you know of this right
is that about right it was about a year
or so
yeah nine and a half months from uh
diagnosis until his graduation from this
world and i and i wonder if if
having him go through
those nine months
in a way kind of forced you and your
family and of course hayden himself
to really
confront death to look at it
in the face to start to get
used to the idea and dare i say even
perhaps somewhat comfortable with the
fact that it it's coming as opposed to
i think so many people who lose people
unexpectedly um could you talk about
what that the what the experience of
thinking about death during those nine
months was i mean obviously certainly
i'm certain you had hope and and you
know you were trying to be optimistic
and
and uh believe that something you know
could possibly happen that would
change hayden's fate but you must have
known all along that death was a very
real possibility how did that prepare
you
for
um hayden's passing
great question and you know i'm i am
grateful
that we had that nine months nine and a
bit months with hayden because
of course we were not expecting that he
would die we thought we were in the best
medical hands
and there was a there was a real chance
of a cure
so we entered this journey not looking
forward to death but doing everything we
can to keep him alive and hopefully
return to good health
but the minute anybody hears the words
you have cancer
it's got to cross your mind that this
might not
might not be the end that we expect you
know cancer has this sort of ominous
tone to it uh this ring that wow maybe i
won't survive it so we had that
period of becoming potentially
accustomed
um to an outcome
where he wouldn't survive this world
and i say in the book that
i was grateful for that i it crushes my
heart to think of what parents must go
through
when there's suddenly an awful
death of a child that is sudden and
without any opportunity to prepare or to
say goodbye
so
yes we had nine and a bit months with
hayden to
to be on our toes
to be conscious that this could be the
outcome
but i think each one of us could live
like that with our children
and our friends and ourselves
and actually find that our lives become
more
alive
ironically
in the presence of death
become more alive
more
conscious um
more respectful
you know if you're told you only have a
week to live you might live that week
differently
than if you were not told you had a week
to live if you have a day to live yeah
you know what what would you do in that
day you would totally
live it with purpose
yeah the the stoics used to uh always
say memento mori like remember you are
going to die and that would actually be
when the caesars would walk or the
generals would walk down the street they
would have a stoic philosopher walking
behind them with like a megaphone saying
momento mori as the crowds are cheering
them walking down the streets in a
parade remember you're going to die
remember you are going to die it is
humbling
and
uh and very helpful and and very similar
to the it's so much fun at parties
but uh it also reminds me of the native
american saying which is you know today
is a good day to die which was a
frequent
uh
native american brave or warrior
saying that would say each morning like
um
it's a kind of a daily reminder because
it does allow you to live the day in a
different way by remembering your
mortality but you know i wanted to uh
jump to a question
the the reason that i know you and and
know your family is uh we're both
members of the baha'i faith and have
some friends in common and um
you know the baha'i faith has some
really beautiful spiritual teachings
about death
as a transition to another plane of
existence we're on a physical plane
right now we take with us our
our soul our spiritual qualities our
our our virtues like our honesty and
kindness and humility and
um all of our compassion these are the
things that we take with us we don't
take with us our
our tesla and our
folding chairs and our laptops we are
taking these qualities with us into this
whatever this next plane of existence is
and
um there's there's hundreds thousands of
uh
amazing and beautiful quotes from the by
faith about
death but one of the famous ones by the
founder of the baha'i faith baha'u'llah
he says i have made death a messenger of
joy to thee wherefore dost thou grieve
and you're kind of tipping your hat to
that in your answer here but
were you somehow able
to live in this dichotomy of death is
the most tragic thing it's the most
horrible thing it's it's heart-wrenching
how in the hell is death a messenger of
joy
and how could baha'u'llah say death is a
messenger of joy wherefore why do you
grieve when it's a messenger of joy from
from the beloved from our divine creator
did you struggle with that was it a
cinch give us some insight
you know until hayden's journey
i thought baha'u'llah's statement i have
made death a messenger of joy to thee
was more metaphorical
that it could really be joy i
i guess i believed it because i'd read
it you know and i
i believe there is extraordinary truth
uh in these writings of baha'u'llah but
yeah it's as you said it's somehow
almost weird it's you know it's beyond
what we can even comprehend especially
for our own child
um
but you know there are a couple of
things first of all
how do you look forward
to death right like how do you imagine
joy you know in something that is so
obviously tragic
you know abdul bahar when he was asked
that question he said
how does one look forward
to the goal of any journey
and you know hayden saw this journey of
life
as being ultimately a journey not to
death as the end
but to death as a doorway to whatever
lay beyond so he saw it as a doorway to
an adventure we don't know what that
adventure looks like you know we have
some little clues from the writings or
the sayings of the world's religious
teachers
but it's a mystery the next world is a
mystery but hayden believed in it he
believed that death was not the end
so
he actually
accepted that there was something beyond
and he believed there was something
beyond and he i almost want to say he
looked forward to it you know when he
knew there was no alternative
um
like
looking forward to the goal of a journey
to the
more abundant life that lay beyond
the
question that we're tackling in this
episode is what can death teach us about
life and the book is called
19 and it details 19 lessons um that you
learned from the loss of your son and i
wonder
if there's you know a couple of one or
two lessons in particular
that
have really stuck with you the most that
you could share with us you know there's
a chapter on
detachment
and or really not a chapter it's a
lesson on detachment and
in it
we share that one day hayden received
a sweet little video from
a young man in wales actually who'd
never met hayden but his wife
um had met hayden and told that told
this fellow
that um
[Music]
hayden robots was in a
very critically ill state he had brain
cancer
and this young fellow who had ms
sent a little video to hayden
and in it he talks about some things and
then he looks straight into the camera
and he says hayden
you are not your body
and
that was a powerful single take home
message and i think hayden got it and i
heard it and it just like went right to
my heart
you are not your body so what are you
then right
so i i think that was a powerful message
and so i use that
kind of like a tagline in the
in the lesson on detachment
that we are
much more
than our bodies
and so in that in that chapter we look
at some things that we did
where we practiced that learning you
know hayden did some meditation
uh during his illness
uh one meditation he did we might call
it a meditation you might call it a
visualization
and in this visualization which a dear
friend of ours sent to us and we just
listened to it
uh on hayden's phone but basically
you
feel your self in your body you feel
your toes and your knees and your legs
and your torso and you
become one with your body and then in
the visualization you
then step away from your body or you
visualize your body from the ceiling of
the room so you look down on this thing
we call your body that's in the bed
and then you go above the ceiling and
you go above the building and you look
down and then you go above the building
and you look down at the street and the
city and then you go higher up and you
look down at the
state
and the country and the ultimately the
planet and there is this beautiful
planet and you admire its majesty
its serenity its peacefulness its unity
and then little by little in the
meditation you come down back
closer through the clouds and to the top
of the building and then to the top of
the ceiling in your room and then you go
back into your body and actually that
that visualization or that meditation
helps us to realize that we can get out
of our bodies
you know we are more than our bodies in
that visualization we prove it right in
the mind
we can experience things
that are able to see the body at a
distance
and this is something that is practiced
in some forms of meditation
in some practices of mindfulness
where we separate ourselves and take a
look you know it helps us to take a more
honest
look a less involved
look you know when you see you know here
we are we're a body watching the
television
on the sofa this is something michael
singer says in his book the untethered
soul
you know here we are instead of being a
body sitting on a sofa watching a tv
now step back and be the one
who observes
the body on the sofa watching the tv
right and all of a sudden when we see
ourselves in that way we become more
mindful
more mindful of that body and its
purpose
it is a temple it is a vehicle
so
these are tools these are exercises we
might call them spiritual exercises
um that help us to live our lives more
consciously
more mindfully more aware
of that body and its relationship to the
mind
that ultimately controls it
ultimately directs it
and when we talk about mind we don't
mean brain
right the mind uses the brain as a as an
organ
but
the mind is a spiritual quality
and
like love and kindness
gentleness generosity these are all
spiritual qualities and they manifest
themselves
through
the body and its actions
but they are not the body
and we are not our bodies the body
ultimately is a bag of bones we're going
to put it in the earth and say goodbye
to it it will have done its job
um and that's not that's not death
that's the death of the body
the real me
keeps going
so when we even talk about death
what's the take-home method message
is that let's think about what is
actually dying
a bag of bones
is dying
i don't mean to trivialize it or to
superficialize it
but it's important to think again about
what really is dying
the in the in tibetan buddhism they
actually undertake
a um a death meditation
and it's really gruesome like this is
something that i think americans could
really benefit from
which is
uh
you literally are picture yourself lying
and you picture your final breaths and
you picture your
your lungs stop moving and your heart
stops beating and
you
picture your life flashing before your
eyes and you have that whole experience
and then you're moving away from your
body into like a world of light and um
and they take you out my uncle did this
with uh at a at a at a tibetan buddhist
retreat and he said it was just
excruciating and profound but apparently
they do it on a regular basis like it
ends up and it's very very moment by
moment extremely thoughtful going back
to that memento mori thing and you know
what lessons can we
take away
from the act of death for our lives to
enrich our lives
this idea of conscious dying or
meditating on one's death and
consciously approaching that moment of
death
preparing not so much our bodies but our
soul our spirit
for dying
is a profound
um
profound experience and interestingly
here we were as a family
trying in our lives to practice
conscious living
and now faced with the opportunity
and the privilege
to practice conscious dying
that's what hayden was doing and you
know
he had that
as a as a gift maybe
you know that he was able to prepare his
thoughts his mind
uh to die
so yeah it wasn't it wasn't a fun
journey
it wasn't
joyous
um it was a little bit scary a little
bit nerve-wracking but it was a journey
that was
conscious it was purposeful and there
were moments of intense beauty
when we were
praying together or being together was
smiling together or hayden
even telling jokes
with us in the room to make us smile i
mean really it was an extraordinary
journey sort of bittersweet
bittersweet experience together these
are gorgeous stories uh adam the book is
just uh beautiful everyone 19 19
insights learned from a 19 year old with
cancer i'm
deeply deeply sorry for your loss like i
said i can't even imagine uh having a
teenage son you know
right now i i won't go there but um the
way that you
vulnerably expertly succinctly
turned
um these this tragic and uplifting nine
and a half months that you went through
into
these beautiful morsels of spiritual
wisdom um is
what a great legacy because that's what
you've that's what you've done is you've
created a legacy
for hayden and i suppose that's that's
really what we all want you know i do
that sometimes when i
when i think about you know an essay i'm
writing or finishing a book or doing a
movie even like oh this is part of my
legacy if anyone ever cares whatever
happened to that
that weird big-headed
baha'i actor that was on the show the
office back in the day then
they'll be able to oh there's a book or
there's an essay or there's a movie or
uh and i i somehow hope that lasts but
you have created a um
an incredible legacy
for hayden
and um
it's a it's a beautiful perspective and
you just read a little bit of the book
and it shifts your
your perspective on how you're living
just that very day i had to i had i
couldn't kind of plow through it's not a
book i could plow through i could kind
of just
read a few pages a day and uh really
loved it so thank you for sharing your
experience and um
so many uh brilliant
uh takeaways
it's gorgeous we're really grateful guys
i wonder whether it might be
meaningful
um
to read the last paragraph of the book
you know just because it was hayden's
legacy it was his wish um if we talk
about legacy you know hayden
hayden did leave notes in his little
notebook and on his mobile phone
and to some extent we could call him a
will um there is one bit one part of the
the notebook that looks like it really
was a will he sort of wrote it like you
know put a call that will
he didn't finish it
but here is what he said he said
i don't want
people to disrupt their lives grieving
keep working
keep loving
keep smiling
keep contributing to the community
i want to be a beacon of joy and
happiness
whether alive
or in the next world
please fulfill this wish for me
if i am unable to do so myself
try whenever you can to bring a smile to
people's faces
to be a light in a dark room
so do what you can
to help others
so i think the legacy
is to take that
and try in whatever way i can
to fulfill that wish as he asked us to
what an incredible legacy and uh that
message of
service
joy
purpose
um
and the hope
the hope piece that is absolutely
incredible that someone could go through
that and feel even more hope
for themselves their family and humanity
you know
that is that's a that's a powerful
message thanks again adam robarts the
book is 19. thank you adam i hope people
will check it out thanks for joining us
all the way from early morning in bali
thank you metaphysical milkshake thanks
reza thank you rain thank you for your
team
it's a great privilege to have been
acknowledged and given this space
to talk about my son hayden
and the book 19
that seeks to honor him and to learn
from his
his journey through cancer thanks guys
well it's hard to know where to go uh
from that um
i really i really
appreciate how open and honest adam was
and
you know how he was willing to share
what must have been a
just a
unimaginable
loss i can't you know you and i are both
fathers i kept putting myself in his
place and i i just i feel like
there's no way that i could do what he's
doing right now go around
the country go around the world talking
about
you know my son and what people can
learn from his experiences really really
grateful for his presence on this pod
it's uh it's a tragic story i love how
he turned his legacy into one of hope uh
in such brave fashion and listen
listeners we'll be giving away copies of
adam's new book 19 the first five people
that write a review of metaphysical
milkshake on the apple podcast app just
take a screenshot of that review email
it to metaphysical at cast media dot com
that's with cast with the k metaphysical
at cast media.com will be sent a copy of
the book
so copy the book so we would love to
hear from you
um about your thoughts on death lessons
from death perhaps someone close to you
passed away and
you uh gleaned something from it some
kernel of wisdom we would love to hear
from you or if you have your own life's
big questions find us on social media at
reza aslan and at rayne wilson on
twitter metamilkpodcast and on instagram
please follow us at metaphysical
milkshake on instagram
let us know your life's big questions
and we might explore them on a future
episode
and please remember to follow rate and
review metaphysical milkshake on apple
podcasts or wherever you listen to
podcasts and of course you can always
subscribe to the metaphysical milkshake
youtube channel watch our full episodes
every week see you next time thanks
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it is produced by safa
samazadeh yazd harris lane mick dimaria
hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
imagine going around at a party with an
iphone you are going to die
remember you are going to die
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you